if you think the RNC is all about Donald
Trump you'd be wrong because there's one
name that looms even larger Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton Hillary Rodham
Clinton and sources say she's been here
the whole time
oh wow I 505 okay going up hilary's
going up oh here we go
bye
I would like a nacho grande
South African yeah I'm sorry
how are you can I expect your vote in
November Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton
Hillary heard of me nice to meet you
give it up for Ted am i right Ted theory
how do you delete all emails
hippie at it
oh mama didn't raise no quitter
Hillary Clinton's message is that things
will never change never ever Trump was
Donald Trump tonight and I thought that
he reminded at foreign audience
Oh